destiny too baby it's coming out 20 17
17 gonna bring a some sort of large
expansion pack in 2016 yeah good I
wasn't sure if they said fiscal 2016 or
if they meant 2016 I think they made 20
16 2016 I think it's gonna be 2016 I
would assume it would probably be in
that like anniversary type range of like
September yone the kind of the game came
out originally so taken King has done a
really well for them by far the most
popular expansion pack 25 million
registered users she's a good expansion
yeah i mean it is the expansion of fixed
yeah for sure problems appeared right
and so I what do you want somebody who
like has played a lot of Destiny
especially last year you're kind of off
the boil like doesn't the contents not
there right now right like you're not
playing destiny right the mall ah I did
I hadn't played for a while and then
this week I played a little bit because
they had an event they had like a
Valentine's Day event yeah double XP now
they don't have my partner but yeah but
it but it was fun it was a 2v2 pvp was
kind of the big stand out there but they
also have new emotes that you can spend
with microtransactions including uh you
know the strange dance I think which is
essentially hotline bling oh really yeah
yeah yeah and then there's like the
awkward dance which is Napoleon Dynamite
so all that's yeah that's like some some
2004 World of Warcraft elf [ __ ] sure
yeah exactly i guess they already own
the animation yeah but uh drag and drop
write this i was exactly but I played a
little bit uh there you go by two days
worth yeah exactly uh well yeah it was
it was fine I'm not playing it like I
used to but then again part of the
reason to is my raid group stop playing
right kind of the weekly we would get
together and we play so that's why these
things matter right these are temple
releases because then you're like all
right we're back in right yeah but
there's also the problem of when people
quit and they were already kind of star
for content yeah I'm kind of getting
bored it's harder to bring them back
it's true you gotta come on that sugar
you gotta keep fresh supply in their
bloodstream at all time like I am
struggling to
actually get one of my raid members to
come back whenever this expansion comes
out because he's like I think I'm just
done yeah I think you're dying minutes
and and then my other and then the other
inmates like oh yeah you know if you get
him to play I'll play too but we'll make
new plays and it's like great now I have
to do this weird friendship managing
thing where it's like all right I guess
if I want to raid with these guys again
I go I want to go see the film but it's
not a really good film it's kind of a
shitty one and but like if you could
just get like when your friends go the
class is going yeah I had the hardest
time getting people to go see Magic Mike
XXL oh really you do so that was not a
good movie did you see his pecs I loved
the first one like I generally you see
you're joking i have not seen either one
but i gotta now everyone knows that you
have [ __ ] line & sinker i'm ok with that
uncomfortable my masculinity if I heard
that movie was funny I would go see it
but never no response mike is genuinely
good movie it is yes you're the first
person who's ever said that to me okay
if you go in with Lo and off
expectations Magic Mike it's a
surprising movie it's not what you think
it is kind of is it a second one is
exactly what you think it should have it
anyway sorry too much magic mic check
happening and die a blue sex says eric
already planning the week-long flew to
have I ran the game's release please are
you looking forward to are you looking
forward to like a new expansion pack are
you more looking forward to like a
destiny sequel um I think just because I
don't know if I'm used to it now I am
looking forward to an expansion
especially if it sounds because it
sounds like it's going to be probably as
big or somewhat close to taking king
size not so much so smaller ones that
they did release in which case that
means there's gonna be a raid the kind
of done with those one's right this one
yeah it seems like those are done
because they're doing these little
events like wow esque i guess in a way
but it sounds like it's going to be a
little bit bigger probably because it
has to be bigger it has to make it until
destiny to write its kind of got to keep
your interest for a little bit yeah um
so looking forward to the raid I mean I
think that's the funniest part of
destiny it's still one of the kind of
the obstacles though for them a little
bit because they don't have a system in
place where if you don't really know
people to play with you know to
experience that but if they have all the
single player stuff to I'm looking
forward to it and I don't need to take a
week off because i'll be playing in the
office
you go the beauty of working at gamespot
com yeah we're very lucky yeah so do you
think they'll have to add eventually
some sort of ability to group up with
randoms because it's a cement wall if
like they had that core group of people
who were playing all the time so if it
does become a little bit more disparate
I don't know the mechanics of these
other communities but it seems to be
something that enough people are calling
for right yeah I mean the interesting
thing is right now there are tools but
they're not within the game right there
are like websites and stuff you can use
thumb ready ready as well yeah but they
generally work out and most of the time
surprisingly the people aren't dicks and
there's been a surprising amount of
community strength in terms of people
that Sherpa other people and they're
really good about it like live streamers
and whatnot but yeah hopefully and
hopefully by destiny to I don't think by
this expansion you're going to see
anything like that i would i would hope
that by destiny to there's some type of
in-game mechanic because they already
have kind of matchmaking type stuff and
they do have numbers behind your
character right so they can probably
take that mat and say okay well you're
within this range this is fits the raid
range you guys should be able to play
together and class specific type thing
hopefully i don't know we'll see and i
guess last point on this for destiny to
whatever they're calling the thing what
does that game need to be does it need
to be like a similar slice of gameplay
but just like new maps new areas new
story new campaign or do you want like a
burning crusade type of like game that
takes what's there already adds more
like sort of quality of life stuff maybe
connects it up a little bit more fluidly
like what is it that you want particular
are you happy with what's there with
would you be happy without like
disappearing and going to one side and
like a new game appearing or you want to
would you like to keep that is important
that that sort of stuff remains and that
there's more layered on top um i think
it would be nice to see maybe like two
more new planets or something like that
i think that the game is always going to
revolve around some of the stuff that's
already there it does a pretty good job
of that now there's all these areas that
you know people walk through and then
there oh this is part of DLC or
something and then they expand on it and
you're like oh that's pretty cool you
know they do a good job of all these
like the scenery and stuff like that is
beautiful it's a thing that i don't
think enough people talk about you
walk around and you can see something
and remember that and have a memory of
that but I think I I want them to build
upon the world that they have now I
really want them to kind of go even more
so towards the story that they've kind
of slowly have fixed a little bit now
with taking king and I think if I read
the news today they got I think bungee
has hired the Mass Effect Andromeda guy
or person their story there I think and
hopefully that person helps create a you
know bigger story progressed until the
North back in the booth yeah yeah think
we're Dinklage this [ __ ] double down
on that guy ya see thank you so much
Eric tightly expertise I guess really
appreciate it folks nejad chiming in as
well Brooks be saying huge ready to be
very cool team toaster once destiny to
to be a prequel I love us know what you
want at a destiny to in the comments
below
you